i'm very exciting it's very exciting i'm
very you are excited
she is very excited how are you i've
been told that story so many times the
viewers are gonna change the channel if
we do it again
it's rare it's a rarity
[Music]
today we're at a high school and there
are all these kids who go to the school
and
and they're around me and like talking
to me and it's it's pretty
weird because i never think that kids
will really like my music because it's
more ballads and stuff like that with
the exception of this
record
i'm very fortunate to have had two
number one records
and for my first two records ever put
out
and of course it's like now it's like
you don't really want to pay attention
to but you're like okay looking at the
chat so i went up this week i went down
this week whatever
but um you know just as long as i can
have a long career and continue to sing
until i die then that's what's going to
make me happy
[Music]
i get up i start singing i put the radio
on well sometimes i wait like an hour
depending on how horseman and then
i just i'm singing constantly
the song is called make it happen and
it's sort of
um a story that is semi-autobiographical
about
my life and it's um it's sort of trying
to send a message to
you know young people but people of all
ages that if you really believe in
something and you really
set your mind that that's what you're
going to do you can make it happen
and as i'm singing it and i'm up there
performing for all these people it's
kind of like you know it's it's
me realizing that this is happening you
know this has happened for me so
it's very emotional
i'm just getting used to this video
thing it's kind of new for
me we basically wanted to keep it as
simple as possible to really let the
song
come across we didn't want to overshadow
the song with a lot of
crazy imagery or whatever so it's just a
straightforward
pretty straightforward performance piece
i've seen this part
you forgot those words huh
[Music]
that's it all right we went to the third
verse okay i just feel like if i can
give something back
to people for everything that i have
then it's the least i can do and i love
kids and i love
singing and being with the kids so it's
it's great it's a really great
experience for me it makes my christmas
[Applause]
sitting there in a room full of stars
and people that i've looked up to from
my whole life i mean i was sitting next
to patti labelle who's such an influence
and
such an inspiration and then looking up
and like watching michael jackson
perform my whole life he's been like the
biggest star so
i mean it's it's a great experience for
me as well it's fun for me
i'm drinking my tea right here
honey lemon zinger table tricking my
teeth
my tea honey yes this is um a necessary
thing for me before i go on stage
my little remedy because the baby's been
a little has a little cold
he's calling me the baby don't don't
think don't confuse them
don't let them think there's a baby here
he calls me the baby i've done top of
the pops a few times yeah it's it's been
it's like
the number one show in england they've
been doing it forever
like since tv began i think
i don't know but it's been around for a
really long time and um how's the crowd
every day
they're really cool yeah they're really
great i love going over there
and um you know it's an experience you
want to hear a new song i just wrote
nobody has heard it yet
it's really good why don't you call me
it's called
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you get a little slap happy during
these rehearsals
i'm not singing anymore it's two to nine
am i right i'm back here but i can't
quite get it all but it's two
yeah very exciting see this is the
little thing that
when they uh i guess this is i've never
presented but i guess they opened this
up and
it's cute so what are you going to do
with the award
um i'm going to put it in my dressing
room which is where i keep
my awards mysteries of the unknown is a
theme tonight
do you believe unknown what do you think
could happen tonight
i have absolutely no idea but with this
crowd you never know
i'm gonna make myself look like a
freaking [ __ ] if i can
i probably can't even hit this thing on
right oh we bad calm down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
have you given this this baby diva and
your advice her advice she knows exactly
what she's doing
she has more than enough people to give
her advice really
yes i love mariah carey i was i honored
this
in okay tonight i was very happy to have
her here
because she's got a great just a great
vibe about it i mean you know i'm fine
you know what i'm saying
congratulations tonight thank you really
special thank you yeah
but you've been honored in every way
possible at this point in your career
what does this kind of thing mean to you
well it seems like
i've been out longer than i have it's
just because i've had so many
records you know come out one after
another but it's amazing
i take this cough drop out because it is
not working with my voice here
madonna also here tonight did you
congratulate her on a new baby
no i didn't i didn't see her what
have you had to build a wing on your
house for all the awards that you're
getting
well i actually just moved into a new
apartment and i just uh
kind of reorganized the award thing and
it's nice i mean it's really
especially when it's an award from the
people from the fans um
it's it's very rewarding to feel that to
feel the love from the former fans
but you are a young diva you're going to
be singing to a queen diva yes i
am one of the biggest queen divas out
there fatty
now has she influenced your career
coming up um i think she's influenced
most um young r b singers out there
today so i'm just
happy to be a part of the event yeah are
you a little nervous about it
oh yes i am singing for patty you got to
get some vocal rest
[Music]
all i can say to you is you know how to
make an entrance oh
thank you liam and so do you oh my
goodness the ensemble
this is one dangerous dress mariah it is
yeah
i was being conservative tonight hello
loves
what um germany
i mean tonight oh tonight i'm gonna eat
some food hopefully
and then i'm going to go to a party i
believe i don't know where
i'd even see the original star wars when
i was little i was i didn't like those
kind of movies i liked you know benji
and stuff about
dogs and things i didn't i didn't like
those kind of things but i guess i guess
i got to rent
the old one first and then get to a new
one we did it in like a school play i
played like one of the characters of
star wars but i don't remember but i
never saw it i didn't tell anybody
because i was embarrassed because you
know you're supposed to see it but hey
i was watching benji i've been trying to
shed this whole cinderella image but my
shoes keep breaking
so i'm walking around with one shoe and
it happened to me tonight right after i
got done singing and it also happened
at madison square garden only at the
garden it was in between in the middle
of a song
so i'm walking around like on one leg
hopping and singing and at the end i
just said i just threw the shoe
to a fan and they were like yay you know
but i'm like don't wear it because it's
going to break
it was actually the same designer won't
say who
but yes i was in a quick change room on
the side of the stage because i wasn't
going to change it then i actually had
to
unfortunately i had another little
ensemble from versace waiting in the
wings and some shoes i would have been
barefoot in versace
which could be cute versace sounds like
a new new movie actually
actually it does no one steal that title
you look beautiful tonight what are you
wearing
vera wang of course
mariah jean gonna be uh debuted in your
video
the mariah jean that was already debuted
and ripped off
poppity pal
what about the band on top the band the
bandana
yeah you already know about the bandana
top they better not foil me with that
top man
very angry about that just kidding just
kidding
yeah how do you know about the hiding
over the top
you're good okay thank you
okay you're fixing my wardrobe
malfunction and i heard
that you had a near disaster almost you
have no idea
the condensed version is the dress i
wore on stage for the opening number of
a live
performance on the american music awards
first performer
nobody to fill in just in case was a
dress that i really love
they're literally sewing it on me as i'm
running to the stage
so i'm just like standing up walking
down the stairs doing my thing holding
this
then i start singing and i'm like i'm
like
just let it die and i'm like wait a
minute
i cannot hear myself so i start pulling
ear monitors out i'm holding up dresses
and i'm trying to like
just get through it team backstage
exclusively with mariah carey
and tonight she wins
one
two g three
and then you got a legend award also did
anybody else win an award did anybody
else win an award tonight
i do believe a lot of wonderful people
won awards no this is
this was an amazing honor let me hold
someone let me help you
so i could be balanced out you know yeah
this is a nice good arm workout
holidays christmas what are you gonna do
i'm leaving in a day or two i'm doing my
first bit of christmas shopping tonight
maybe right after this
very excited yes where are you gonna go
i'm gonna go to the mall
mariah since they announced you're gonna
be on idol i literally wept in the
studio
unicorns and rainbows came out i came
charging i can't even breathe right now
i'm sorry
no butterflies were there no of course
the butterflies were mariah the
butterflies
were there okay bye et thank you for
coming today
[Music]
bye